you I was surprised to see it was very
dope to see you and T get together but
obviously him and Sarah have like an
interesting history not necessarily like
super crazy but
you and Sada came up I mean I've met you
through Sada baby was that like a an
easy project to make happen separate of
like it was an easy project to make
happen because I don't put my business
in personal stuff together and plus
um I don't I don't get into people that
already know each other business like I
don't do that I don't like I think
um I don't even think the world should
know that business is because it's just
it's personal for sure
um I'll try to separate personal
feelings when I do business but
um T ain't doing nothing to me I I'm
actually cool as hell with t right now
like we're cool as hell he's a great
dude he's a great dude like I [__] with
him has he uh invited you to his Grand
Theft Auto server yeah he just he really
just got my [__] built he so are you
online like playing games I just got it
Bill he um he sent somebody to my house
and he sent me like oh so you have like
a gaming rig yeah he built me like a six
thousand dollar PC or something oh [__]
yeah I just got built right before I got
to Cali like three days ago so so you're
about to be you're about to be a GTA
acting I'm Charles Jones the mechanic so
in GTA you already have your character
Charles Jones The Mechanic and you can't
break character while on the mic no I'm
Charles Jones the mechanic and if you
need Strikers I ain't saying I got them
but I ain't saying I don't got them I
love it for people who don't know what's
happening
there is this role-playing online pocket
of Grand Theft Auto and if you're in it
you gotta play the character yeah I
ain't saying I got Strikers but I ain't
saying I don't got Striker's life what
is a striker I mean
the the things the Sticks no no Strikers
I don't know what a striker is I don't
play [__] fast cars oh okay okay okay
so you are the guy you're The Chop Shop
guy not the mechanic but I got Strikers
okay if y'all need Strikers call Charles
Jones in the game CJ CJ in the game what
happens if you break character do you
get killed I think you can put out the
server but I'll Never Break characters
so I won't know wow I feel like that
inadvertently you being Charles Jones on
a GTA server is going to help your
acting career shortly for sure because
you're going to be in movies for sure
I'm calling it now have you ever like do
you have those aspirations yeah I'm in a
Toby movie that just came up of course
you are yeah how terrible is it it went
terrible it was fire
I was the lead role bro I just go on
Twitter every month or so and I'll just
type in 2B and hit videos and just see
the clips so you're you're the lead
actor in The 2B movie yeah what's it
called outside
are you outside in it yeah I'm outside
yeah how what's the can you give me a
synopsis of what what the plot is oh
it's basically
um talk about how kids jump in gangs and
be in the streets and um I'm I'm going
to school I get kicked out of school a
lot
um and the girl when I pull up the
trailer real quick yeah one of the girls
in the movie died and it was supposed to
happen like we posted gave her a fake
perk or something but
it just caused us to have so many Ops
people's online talking about it all
types of people getting shot on live
Instagram live basically everything is
going on I can't find the truth
did you watch uh
did you watch the skillet baby uh short
or the uh T Grizzly short films for his
last album no I didn't all right
actually really good I gotta go watch it
now not a bad actor
very very like uh that whole project was
just like straight up like a visual like
if you if you ain't watching the [__]
movies you're probably not might not get
it I ain't gonna lie um and I told this
to T I feel like this year like other
than him coming out when he just blew up
crazy big I feel like he been rapping
like the best ever like I feel like he
just I've been in studio with him he's
been going he like he'd be making me be
like damn what the
like you feel I was gonna say what is is
it a is it uh is it something where you
guys are cutting some of these records
and obviously you get inspired to go
harder but is there also any sort of
like friendly competition no it's a
friendly competition like I'm gonna get
animals like we had never say it but
it's like he didn't say something so
crazy that I've like the whole room
would be like man you better go and then
I say something he'll be like man I got
like T when I first met him he was just
like he got to do this one thing like
they only talk about Lil Wayne and Jay-Z
doing like right he just go to the mic
and just do a 16 off just off the top of
his head
and it'd be like the craziest stuff I I
didn't heard and stuff but then he like
man sometimes I gotta write because you
be saying some crazy stuff so it's
really cool I was gonna say there's
something about what's in the water in
Detroit right now between yourself we
talked about cash kid baby Tron just
these like great one-liners that you're
just like oh [__] or it's like
especially with the sports bars and [__]
like there's something about the sports
bars that you have that cash kids got
that baby tron's got we're just like
Jesus they kind of got a no to know like
random NBA references and [__] like
what's your favorite
bar you have in your phone right now
that you've written recently give me a
line give me a one line that you just
you just wrote recently you're like oh
when people hear this
uh
my my new way I kill people I let them
live oh
I like that that's deep yeah I said I
found a new way to kill people I just
let them live
Heap
I look forward to uh well I don't look
forward to it but you know what's coming
there's gonna be so many people making
these Titanic submarine bars in the next
like two weeks
I don't wanna I don't want to make fun
of the people no they died I feel like
it's [__] up what's happening because
it's like a lot of people lost their
life and it's become like a joke online
I think um
there's no sense around people in the
world no more and that's a big deal like
I think that's a big deal to me like
people making fun of people dying and
stuff that's not like when you do it in
your own household or something it's
cool like but why put that into the
world for the world to consume why add
to that people like laughing at negative
stuff like going online and trying to
say the most negative stuff possible is
not funny to me how do you try to
disconnect from like reading comments or
like paying too much attention to some
of the online [__] because I used to not
read them like I used to not read them
and not just because it's negative it's
just be like I don't want to get caught
up and I know Fame is a drug like when
you hire you hide when you love you low
but I read them not and I laugh at them
I do all because I I I know myself I'm
strong enough not to care I don't care
you don't think subconsciously it might
somehow like be up there not because I
um I know how to decipher
um fact from fiction so it'd be like if
you say this I know this ain't true and
if you say this I know it is true so you
do got the right to say that because
it's true and then it just be like I use
a lot of it for motivation or like
um I like I'm I'm my biggest critic so I
just be wanting to see what people do
and don't like about me so do you feel
like because I feel like you've improved
immensely over the last few years just
as an artist as a rapper
um
do you ever go back and listen to like
stuff or hear stuff that's like maybe a
few years old and be like damn I was
like I'm so much better now like I swear
I listen to a lot of stuff and my voice
be like like you like you say I got
bigger and stuff and then my voice used
to crack and I used to be like sounding
like a real little kid so yeah I was
listening somebody was telling me a song
that I made a few years ago and I was
telling them like man I sound like a kid
it was trash for sure I do that all the
time how uh important is it for you to
keep like pushing yourself as a as an
emcee because you care about I feel like
you you're a high level rapper you know
what I'm saying I talked to Chris Brown
one time like a couple weeks ago I was
at his rehearsal with TM I asked him
like how do you stay grounded and you
told me I act like I didn't accomplish
nothing so I think that's Mo that's most
important you act like you just like my
coach used to tell me when I get an end
zone act like I've been there before so
I just act like I don't do nothing like
that's the biggest thing that a lot of
somebody didn't told me in a while Chris
Brown told me that I act like he act
like he don't haven't accomplished
anything because if you let uh if you
let your recent [__] get to your head
you're gonna get lazy get lazy yeah get
complacent complacency is the worst [__]
ever man yeah Chris that's a nice just
hanging with Chris Brown see a fan I
don't think he's a fan not yet he is he
he remembered me from when I met him
with Sada a few years ago that's one of
the most humblest people I met
um from my experience he was at my top
two celebrities I ever met was G herbo
and Chris Brown for real and you work
with G herbo yeah